I think people are affected by the
images they see
most of the time that you see images
coming from Kenya specifically and most
of Africa it will be war disease AIDS
famine something like that
while that is true there's still a lot
more coming out of the continent that is
uplifting that is positive that is
encouraging my mission is to change our
own perceptions of what Africa is
supposed to be my name is Mohammad Becca
and I'm a photographer I got into
photography by accident a friend of mine
showed me something on our website and I
was like I probably can do this so I
decided to try it out
originally my mission was to you know
educate the West remote Africa is like
and I realized it doesn't matter what
other people think if we still think of
ourselves as backward or not worthy so
my mission changed to trying to get
people who've grown up in African cities
to learn to see Africa differently if I
can keep shooting what I want people to
see then I believe over time these
changes what people think of themselves
[Music]
I have recently just completed a project
where were claiming communication masts
from all over the country the aim was to
explore different views from this new
perspective I can almost guarantee that
no photographer in Africa in Kenya has
photographed from the heights that I
photographed from so it was a unique
opportunity and a very rare chance for
me
[Music]
we traveled about seven eight days
climbed seven masts in total some go as
high as 100 meters
it was hard climbing but you get to the
top and you see the view that awaits you
and it's like another one
it was beautiful being up there
[Music]
photography has a unique way of being
able to change perceptions just by
seeing something different over and over
and over
all these things are connected to the
value that you place on the place that
you live in I think if we see that what
we have is really beautiful and worth
protecting then we put a lot more effort
into protecting it for ourselves
and for the future
you
[Music]